and here we are a new batman movie and
let you know right out the gate there
are no spoilers in this review this is a
spoiler-free review will there be a
spoiler video that i do later on in the
week absolutely there's a lot to talk
about in this movie not all of which i
can talk about here because well
spoilers there'll be a time and a place
for that but for right now sit back
relax enjoy my spoiler-free review of
the batman
[Music]
so the batman is a new batman movie that
changed hands and changed concepts a lot
throughout the years it's gonna be a
standalone ben affleck batman movie and
then it wasn't and for the uninitiated
for people who don't bathe in comic book
movie nerd them it can get very
confusing i totally get that so to
clarify this is not a sequel or a
prequel to any existing batman movie out
there right now this is a new on-screen
batman adventure not linked to any other
on-screen batman adventures that we have
which if you look at it that is very
comic bookish it's funny that comic book
movies have become so comic books in the
world of comic books they're graphic
novels comic book stories that aren't
linked together they're their own things
it's kind of funny that comic book
movies are doing that while we have one
on-screen batman adventure we'll have
another on-screen batman adventure and
they don't have to be linked that is if
they keep the snyder universe going and
they should but okay in this batman
movie titled the batman robert pattinson
plays the batman there's a new player in
town by player i mean serial killer
which is a new on-screen riddler and as
we saw in the trailer very dark very
broody batman i was gonna call it a
batman adventures it's more of an
investigative batman film broody batman
film in terms of atmosphere the
atmosphere of gotham i thought this
movie really hammered the point home the
point is a point that we've heard in
other batman movies other batman stories
but it's never
fully been realized by me and that is
that gotham is the biggest [ __ ] on
the planet batman why are you even
trying because bruce wayne and batman
they always hear that but i've always
been like yeah but gotham has great
architecture or i'll be like yeah it has
a criminal element but you take out the
mob you have a pretty sweet city on your
hands this movie really hammers at home
it's like no gotham is the worst and
batman might just be fighting a losing
fight i dug the fact that they hammered
that tone home probably helps that 99
of this movie is nighttime right before
sunrise that's in here right at sunset
that's in here no daytime scenes though
feels very gotham it feels very arkham
city that also means robert pattinson is
batman for 95 of the movie though i can
make an argument for 100. but before we
get to the bat and singers and spend a
lot of time talking about that we're
going to talk about support characters
the support characters in this movie
were great i loved colin farrell as the
penguin when you see him in the trailer
you're like that's not colin farrell
when you hear him in the movie you hear
more colin farrell in there point is
though it's one of those castings where
i'm like wouldn't have thought of it and
that's why i do not get paid money to
think of it colin farrell was great in
this movie as was zoe kravitz's catwoman
zoe kravitz's catwoman is a standout in
the batman one could argue that zoey
kravitz says catwoman made for a more
interesting character than batman in a
movie titled the batman which is really
funny that we got the bat the cat the
penguin which is one of the taglines for
batman returns more of a side thought
really but what i liked about it is that
you have
these batman villains and batman
characters in here but you don't get
origin stories for them all makes the
world feel more established more real
like just like yeah gotham exists and
it's existed for longer than batman's
existed really it's the fact that they
all come together in this lived-in
criminal city this criminal world that
makes for the most interesting character
in the movie and that is the city of
gotham itself now with riddler i'm going
to tread lightly because we haven't seen
a lot of the riddler in the trailers
but you do see the fact that obviously
there are kills and riddles that batman
has to solve when confronting riddlers
games and traps and whatnot and i
thought those were great they're messed
up fulfilling violent it was a cool
introduction to riddler into this kind
of world also there's a real
what the hell is going on kind of
feeling you have when you're seeing it
like what's riddler doing and why i'll
talk more about riddler this weekend in
my spoiler talk video also loved the
batmobile in the trailer i was like
seems like a muscle car with a rocket on
the back and it still does feel like
that which if i'm being honest is most
the reason it felt awesome because when
that engine kicks on and that sound
design hits you in the middle of your
chest you're like
also leads to what i think is the best
batmobile chase sequence i've seen in a
batman movie i dug it it was fast it was
exciting it didn't seem overly cgi i
mean cgi is getting pretty good these
days well if i found out oh it was cgi
well it is what it is but if i found out
nope that was a real car chasing another
car i wouldn't be the least bit
surprised it just felt
grit in your teeth real and as much as i
usually forget to talk about musical
scores i made a point to remember to
talk about this michael giaccino's
musical score in here is great it's the
song in the trailer that is that epic
swell and that's you'll listen to it on
youtube 150 times after you watch the
movie now jeffrey wright as gordon
jeffrey wright is a great actor and he
makes the call work the call being if
we're going to have gotham and we're
going to have every element of gotham
every person in gotham be the broodiest
version that they could possibly be for
most of the characters it does work i
think jeffrey wright made that work for
gordon he feels like a gordon who's just
at his wit's ends has the weight of the
world on his shoulders nothing's working
so he's all right this vigilante person
is really doing the only game in town
that looks like it might lead to
anything and i can see why this version
of gordon this super broody gordon went
there but then we get to the broodiest
of broody's robert pattinson as bruce
wayne i say bruce wayne because broody
batman makes sense when he was cast
people like oh he's gonna be super emo
batman i was like hey he out acted
everyone in tenet we will see but hey
internet when you're right you're right
and he is super broody bruce wayne the
problem with robert pattinson's batman
in this movie is the fact that there's
no real differential between bruce wayne
and batman my favorite interpretations
of batman are really you have three
characters working in one body you have
bruce wayne when it's just him hanging
out with alfred no other eyes are around
you have bruce wayne when he's in the
public eye when he plays up that public
persona and then you have the batman and
the three of them feel differently you
know you have this trinity of character
you have the id ego and super ego thing
going on this movie he's broody batman
then he's hanging out with alfred who
really andy circus is alfred's only in
it for a couple scenes not in it much
because for the most part he is out
there doing his thing as batman and
alfred's just not a part of the dynamic
he's not part of the equation but okay
super broody batman he's super broody
when he's with alfred how about the
public eye there's one scene where he
goes into public and
also he's the same kind of broody he's
just the same guy in all three personas
again probably a conscious effort they
wanted to really show how much gotham's
getting everyone down which worked for
gordon in this movie for me but when
he's bruce wayne it just it's a logical
leap that he would have to [ __ ]
people and put on a bs smile because
like well don't want people knowing that
he's possibly batman he'd have a lineup
of a bunch of possible batman suspects
should be able to pick him out
immediately yeah i think broody
billionaire with way too much time on
his hands i i just think he's batman
just a guess
what do i win johnny like he's not even
trying to hide it it made the character
feel so one-dimensional and boring and
that's on top of the fact that when he's
batman he doesn't feel like batman he
doesn't feel mythical he just feels like
a guy went to a sporting goods store and
got some gear now he's batman i feel
like i could go to rei drop some cash
become batman tomorrow it kind of feels
like in mask of the phantasm when bruce
wayne did his trial run as a vigilante
no one really took him seriously it's
that same kind of vibe but for the
entire movie and he has a batman costume
and you might be thinkable these are as
early days as batman he'll get there
eventually but this movie does
illustrate it says that he's been batman
for two years which i believe is longer
than christian bale's batman was batman
by the end of the dark knight again
probably a conscious effort it's just
not one that i felt paid off for a
batman movie he did have a good batman
voice i'll say that he wasn't like
excuse me
a psychopath oh like you know he just
lowered his voice i i dug his batman
voice guys in the end the movie the
batman had a lot that worked for me the
overall tone of gotham the fact that
this is the darkest movie i've seen
since dark city that works too it has
tones of long halloween it has tones of
batman eternal the thing that impressed
me about this movie is how jam-packed it
is it's not just like oh the riddler
comes into town now it's batman versus
the riddler there are a lot of pieces in
this gotham chessboard that are on the
move the batman is an amazing world of
gotham i want to see more from this
world of gotham and although i wish i
was more invested with the batman
character himself i had a good time with
this movie and its world that would be a
good time no alcohol required so i'm
gonna get out of here and i'll see you
this weekend for my batman spoiler talk
until then the batman have you seen it
what did you think about it are you
looking forward to it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you